[Musique]
selon youtube qui vous est désormais
familière nous souhaitons à tous la
bienvenue dans le temps its le seul
temps pensez-y bien ou ce que l'on tient
en général pour un possible à quelques
chances d'être vrai aujourd'hui nous
irons à la rencontre d'une des plus
vieilles peurs de l'humanité celle des
monstres des créatures anormal de tout
ce qui est difforme et aspire la
répulsion à propos de mons où nous
venons d'en parler si tout d'un coup
vous vous trouviez confronter avec une
de ces créatures ces horribles créatures
imaginées par norman spinrad nos rêves
de fer que se passerait-il est bien mais
et vous les ferez fuir avec vos deux
bouts de jambes ou des bras et votre
tête mais vous savez les monstres
ce
cas sans doute un peu raison car le
monstre au fond ce n'est rien d'autre
que ce qui est différent ce qui est à la
lettre ward énorme vous savez n'oublions
pas que le mot monstre lui-même vient du
latin monstre arrêt nous est venu
ensuite le mot montrer le monstre c'est
ainsi ce qui se montre ou ce que l'on
montre du doigt et c'est la raison pour
laquelle sans plus attendre nous allons
maintenant vous les monstres et ses
créatures de cauchemar
dans les légendes limites dans tout ce
qui fait le très ancien passé de
l'humanité il a toujours été question de
créatures monstrueuses comme les
chimères les vampires et loups-garous
les dragons et bien d'autres choses
encore plus près de nous des expéditions
scientifiques sont même régulièrement
formés pour donner la chasse à ces
grandes créatures qui vivrait au fond
des eaux ou au sommet des montagnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais dans la science fiction
eh bien on peut dire que le monstre qui
joue un rôle tout à fait particulier
puisqu'à chaque fois qu'il apparaît dans
l'autre monde normal c'est pour
convoquer une violente crise crise qui
ne pourra d'ailleurs être résolue
qu'avec la disparition de la créature du
cauchemar et bien voyons tout de suite à
quoi il ressent cette fameuse créatures
de cauchemar
cinq fictions nous présente quatre
grandes familles de monde la première
existe déjà tout autour de nous ce sont
par exemple les insectes les araignées
les vers de terre mais pourquoi pas des
micro organismes en raison de leur
petite taille on y remarque pas et il
reste parfaitement inoffensif
mais imaginons maintenant comme l'ont
montré de nombreux auteurs à la suite de
l'explosion d'hiroshima qu'une fourmi où
il n'avait ni après avoir été exposé à
un bombardement radioactifs atteignent
tout à coup la taille d'un éléphant dans
ce cas insecte inoffensif il est alors
annoncée pouvant tard
[Applaudissements]
autres catégories et celle là
extrêmement prolifique celle des
monstres d'aspect préhistorique
là les choses sont simples c'est le
passé de la terre celui où l'homme
n'avait pas encore conquis notre planète
qui fait irruption tout à coup dans
notre présent et menacent de détruire la
civilisation
en effet
pour des raisons que les auteurs ne
s'attaque jamais a expliqué des
dinosaures de l'ère secondaire a été
miraculeusement conservé quelque part
dans les profondeurs de la terre ou sous
les classes du pôle et puis un jour ce
qui doit arriver arrive et le monstre se
révèle alors évidemment il menace de
tout démolir autour de lui y compris la
lande civilisation établi par
mais heureusement la majorité des récits
le passé n'a pas raison du présent et
notre monstre finit toujours par être
éliminé dans ce vestiaire il reste une
dernière famille celle des monstres
extraterrestres
cela on le rencontre chez eux sur la
planète
tapi dans quelques forêts ils attendent
patiemment l'arrivée des explorateurs
mais rassurez vous nos braves
explorateurs grâce à leur courage à leur
ingéniosité et aussi il faut bien le
dire un bon fusil laser arriveront
toujours à se débarrasser de ce gène en
trouble-fête aussi effrayant souhaité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en vérité ces monstres ce redoutable que
par leur times voici maintenant une
nouvelle famille beaucoup plus
effrayante parce que précisément elles
n'ont plus aucun corps matériel
tout comme les effroyables entité
imaginé par l'auteur américain of craft
ce sont des créatures fantomatique boury
l'énergie malfaisante et contre lesquels
les armes classiques sont totalement
impuissants
et pourquoi le monstre et il s'est
répandu dans les récits de science
fiction classique et populaire la
première raison nous vient semble-t-il
de loupe de l'humanité et les billets à
la peur archaïque de l'homme face à la
bête en effet n'oublions pas qu'avant
d'être chasseur l'homme a été chassée et
qu'ils gardent au fond de lui le
souvenir des terribles combats qui jadis
l'opposait aux animaux monstrueux des
premiers âges
mais aussi beaucoup plus chaud elle
coïncide avec le développement de la
société technologique et industrielle
ainsi tous les lecteurs de science
fiction ont pu remarquer qu'au lendemain
de la seconde guerre mondiale les
nouvelles et romans traitant de
créatures monstrueuses se sont
multipliés et en particulier au japon
oui corps pour les écrivains japonais le
monstre l'horreur est là tu as pu et
bien c'est hiroshima c'est la bombe ce
qui nous montre une fois de plus que la
science fiction est bel et bien le
miroir du président
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans notre société
technologique le dragon vert celui qui
autrefois cracher des flammes s'est
modernisé il s'est mise en quelque sorte
au goût du jour
désormais le monstre c'est la machine
c'est elle qui saccagent la nature
autour d'elle détruit tout est construit
un monde impitoyable à sa mesure
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a parfaitement
montré l'écrivait anglais qui bat là
où le monstre mise en acier de pro celui
qui dévore chaque année des milliers et
des milliers de vies humaines les
d'autre que la voiture elle-même vie
d'un montre encore plus gigantesque le
monstre technologies
[Musique]
c'était un film de jan kounen de jean
cau dario jaguar je vous remercie d'être
venu avec nous dans le temps x pour
parler des monstruosités des monstres et
créatures anormal le mot monstre veut
dire avertissements justement et je vous
propose de définir le monstre comme ceux
ci
le monstre c'est un être qui apparemment
n'a pas de sens mais qui probablement
doit en avoir un et ne le révèle pas ce
qui est très inquiétant alors justement
si on s'en tient à cette définition du
nom révélé de ce qui n'est pas dit à
travers le monstre est comme vous
accorder par ailleurs une importante
place à la psychanalyse dans la préface
que vous avez écrit des histoires de
monstres en attendant de se demander est
ce que cette ce monstre cette image de
la monstruosité n'est pas ce qui traîne
un petit peu dans l'inconscience et bien
la conscience individuelle que
l'inconscient collectif de l'humanité
c'est tout à fait normal de penser ça
parce que il n'ya pas que des veaux à
deux têtes et des moutons à cinq pattes
il y à des monstres qui sortent de nos
cervelles qui sont purement et
simplement inventé par l'homme et ses
monstres olemps on aime beaucoup plus
nombreux que les autres alors pourquoi
inventer des monstres et bien tout
simplement parce qu'il ya des choses que
nous avons envie de nous cacher à nous
mêmes il ya des choses que
[Musique]
nous disons de manière voilée que
nous aimons tenir secrète et qui
apparaissent tout de même dans ces
conditions il est difficile de ne pas
parler de psychanalyse bien sûr alors il
ya une question qui est très importante
et qui chagrine un petit peu les tenants
de ce fait virer de cette querelle entre
le fantastique et la science fiction est
ce que il existe selon vous une
différence
distinction à faire entre le monstre du
fantastique et le monstre tel qu'il
apparaît dans la science-fiction
probablement avec le monstre de
frankenstein en 1817 je crois que tous
les monstres sont cousins les uns des
autres ils naissent tous de notre
inconscient mais il ya une différence
manifeste entre le fantastique et la
science fiction c'est que les monstres
fantastiques
semble être d envoyer de l'eau de là je
dis bien semblent être je ne vais pas
plus loin tandis que les monstres de la
science-fiction reçoivent toujours une
explication naturelle un exemple dans la
tradition
on pensait toujours que les jumeaux
étaient des monstres les
la gémellité étant quelque chose de tout
à fait rare apparaissait comme quelque
chose de monstrueux mais dans les
histoires fantastiques qui met en scène
des jumeaux il y en a quelques célèbres
comme seul dauphin man par exemple
l'apparition des jumeaux était un signe
inquiétant et était un message de
quelques au delà au contraire en science
fiction la gémellité est expliquée elle
devient le clonage qui est une source
d'un très grand nombre de paradoxes mais
qui
ne nous fait pas perdre totalement notre
sang froid est ce qu'il existe je dirais
une version moderne du monstre tout à
l'heure nous en avons parlé dans ce film
le monstre n'est-il pas aujourd'hui
quelque part dans la société
technologique est ce qui ne s'est pas
déplacée vers ce qu'on pourrait appeler
les monstruosités dû aux progrès
scientifiques à sa fête à certains excès
de la science et la technologie je
dirais qu'aujourd'hui le monde la notion
de monstre s'est élargi
on en a fini ne par inverser la
monstruosité quelques exemples
d'abord autrefois il était admis que la
créature de frankenstein qui est le
monstre de science-fiction typiques
comme vous l'avez dit était un être
repoussant et tout récemment brian solis
dans un roman intitulé frankenstein des
livres et
nous présente une créature de
frankenstein qui est un très bel homme
et c'est précisément sa beauté qui fait
son étrangeté et sa monstruosité c'est
en cela qu'il nous surprend nous nous
attendions au célèbre maquillage de jack
pierce et nous ne l'avons pas de la même
manière la science fiction nous invite
comme vous l'avait d'ailleurs dit tout à
l'heure à un moment donné sion à
remettre en question les notions les
mieux admise si nous trouvons nez à nez
avec un extraterrestre épouvantable peut
être bien que ce sera l'extraterrestre
qui s'enfuiraient qui auraient peur de
nous jacques goimard je vous remercie en
dehors du livre dangereuse et parlait
tout à l'heure dont nous avons parlé
ensemble histoire de monstre j'aimerais
recommandés très rapidement deux autres
ouvrages qui d'abord dagon aux éditions
j'ai lu qui est un livre dans lequel
l'américain lovecraft exprime tout son
talent à décrire toutes sortes de
monstres et monstruosités et ensuite
toujours aux éditions j'ai lu un livre
de l'américain le prenne 20 de vols la
faune de l'espace qui est un livre à
l'intérieur duquel également on nous
montre toutes sortes de je dirais un
bestiaire consacré aux monstres
extraterrestres
oui mais bon c'est exact et reste mais à
propos des craintes et reste je crois
que nous avons aussi beaucoup de lettres
cette semaine et même des lettres venant
de très loin si les extraterrestres
absolument un inventeur j'espère qu'ils
continueront à nous écrire pour que nous
puissions les rencontrer vous avez été
nombreux à nous poser des questions sur
les ovnis alors je vous conseillerais de
lire le dossier des civilisations
extraterrestres qui a été écrit par jean
claude ribbe et françois virot et qui
est sorti aux éditions j'ai lu
nombreuses questions aussi sur les
séries de télévision alors star trek
comme l'a dit le gars sera bientôt
diffusée sur tf1 et quand un cosmos 1999
ce sera peut-être aussi le cas mais en
tout cas pour le moment suivez en les
nombreux extraits dans le temps x
ensuite eh bien j'en profite pour vous
montrer le dessin de christian bale et
14 ans qui illustre cette dernière série
et que nous félicitons tout son talent
nous avons aussi reçu cette semaine le
livre de daniel fonda neige qui
s'appelle trois thèmes de la science
fiction alors comme l'indiquent son
titre et bien trois thèmes seront
traités tout d'abord la fusée que vous
découvrirez à travers les âges ensuite
le robot du rudimentaire ou plus
perfectionnés et enfin la ville
ce livre intéressant particulier les
formations scolaires car il donne une
très bonne idée du contenu graphique de
la science fiction il est en effet
associée à 30 diapositives
voilà je vous remercie encore pour tout
votre goût lier cette semaine j'ai même
reçu une cassette d'hyères alors je
crois qu'il serait bon que vous soyez si
nombreux à nous envoyer ce genre de
lettre sonore je vous rappelle notre
adresse temps x tf1 bureau 4071 17 rue
de l'arrivée
paris 15e
voilà il est plus que temps de nous
quitter la semaine prochaine nous
retrouverons pour un tout autre dossier
qui sera consacré cette fois aux mutants
les mutants monstrueux et les surhommes
et nous recevons également intrigante
auteur de science fiction française
michel jeury en attendant et bien comme
d'habitude que la grande des galactiques
soit avec vous pousse à tra
[Musique]